Девушки отдыхают... Ja, hallo München, schön, dass ihr da seid!
Wer hätte das gedacht? Podcast-Luf, wo irgendwann mal im Zirkus.
Hey, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid, hallo München, wow, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid zu unserer Skateboard-Show.
Ja. Das waren alle Tricks, die werden wir jetzt nochmal anders performen, aber es wird das selbe bleiben. Wie geht's euch? Geht's euch gut, München? Wow, okay. Sehr schön, es ist wirklich beeindruckend, viele Menschen kommen zusammen, um uns zu sehen, und dann ist man nicht ganz fit. Hast du Husten? Ich habe ein bisschen eine leichte Erkältung. Irgendwas ist anders an dir, ich weiss nicht, hast du neue Ohrringe oder was ist ... Okay, let's address the elephant in the room. Seit langem ist mal wieder ein Elefant hier im Raum, im Zirkus Krone. Tierschutzgemäss natürlich. Elefant. Ich habe mir den Schlüssel übereingebrochen. Okay. Er Applaus wert. Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren! Er ist zerbrechlich, er ist zerstörbar, merkt euch das! Auch ein Stefan Tietze kann brechen! Auch ein Stefan Tietze kann brechen, meine Damen und Herren! Also lasst uns jetzt nicht aufhören, sondern weitermachen! Haben wir uns eigentlich schon vorgestellt, wer hier die ganze Zeit redet, für die UFO-Folge, die ihr hört, traunert, 14, hier eine richtige Zahl einfügt, Floritin Will, meine Damen und Herren, er kommt von hier! Dankeschön, ist nett! Heimspiel! Dankeschön, ist nett! Ja, sorry, warum kam das nicht bei meinem Namen, das ist flackerlich. Es ist nett, vielen Dank, vielen, vielen Dank, ist nicht nötig, ist nicht nötig, ist nicht nötig, Dankeschön, ach, hört auf, ach, hört auf. Dankeschön, Dankeschön, aber auch der Nordflügel ist heute hier, hallo. Dankeschön, okay, okay, bist du dabei. Ist das abgefangen? Das ist eher so die Stephan-Gruppe, ich glaube, mittlerweile hat es sich ja rumgesprochen. Danke. Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, was er gesagt hat. Danke, dass du es wiederholt hast, vielen Dank, freut mich. Ja, jetzt haben wir es auch verstanden, danke schön. Ne, sonst wirst du hier gleich raus, also so kann man es ja auch.
Ich glaube, es hat sich mittlerweile rumgesprochen, wo wir stehen auf der Bühne, das heißt, die Leute können jetzt auch ihren Platz immer so wählen, dass sie einen von uns sehen und das ist jetzt der eine, der in der falschen Zeit gefangen ist. Wie wenn du bei so einem Hockeyspiel bist und dann die Haie gegen die Bären und du schaust dich um und denkst, oh fuck, hier trägt niemand Bären. So für beängstigte Fans, die den Gegner nicht sehen wollen. Ja, ja, genau. Ja, da gibt es ja eigentlich auch so Säulen, weil ich war in meinem Zirkus und habe die Hälfte einfach verpasst, weil ich hinter so einer Säule saß. Ja, der, der hinter dir saß, hat auch die Hälfte verpasst. Das stimmt, weil man ja auch hinter mir, hinter einer Säule sitzt. Hinter einer Maschine sitzt man da. Wahrscheinlich haben die gesagt, komm, lass uns den Langen einfach hinter die Säule setzen. Gross und gross gesellt sich gerne, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Habt ihr alle eine gute Sicht?
Ja.
Sehr gut. Also wenn man dieser Location 1
nicht, ihr auch da unten eigentlich, ihr guckt einfach
gegen die Wand. Doch, Daumen gehen hoch,
Daumen gehen hoch.
Alles gut.
Wie war deine Woche so?
Ganz gut, du hast dir das Schlüsselbein
gebrochen, ich bin jetzt kein Anatom.
Wir sind alle kein Anatom.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten von uns sind Anatomen im klassischen Sinne.
Wir bestehen aus Anatomen.
Vielleicht sind Physiker im Raum, die wissen aus wie viel.
Vielleicht, aber ich versuche es mir nur vom Namen her zu leiten.
Haben wir nicht letzte Live-Show darüber gesprochen?
Ja, wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass alle Knochen faul nach Bein benannt wurden.
Genau, das kommt von Gebeine, weil Knochen auch Gebeine sind.
Ah, du hast die Gebeine von Sandra verbrannt, um es in einem neutralen Satz zu benennen.
So habe ich es mit dem Beispiel verstanden.
Mick, hast du denn die Gebeine von Sandra verbrannt?
Ah, ich verstehe.
Wie gut wäre denn so ein Buchstabierwettbewerb und dann benutzen sie es in einem Satz und die sind immer mega ruhig. Ich habe die Gebeine im Wald versteckt. Okay, können Sie es noch mal in einem anderen Satz? Lara Acht steht auf der Bühne. Können Sie es noch in einem anderen Satz benutzen? Nach dem Essen haben wir die Gebeine in den Mülleimer getan. Ich schau grad da mal, sorry, ich schau grad diese Serie auf Netflix.
Gebeine, G-E-B-B-E-I-N-E.
Leider völlig falsch.
So dass es ein ,,Ä, ja".
Aber jetzt als unerfahrener Anatom, der ich bin, ich sag mal so, die eine oder die Erfahrung mit dem menschlichen Körper habe ich schon gemacht, aber jetzt vielleicht nicht. Zähl mir alle drei Erfahrungen auf, die du mit dem menschlichen Körper gemacht hast. Gerne, ich habe Zeit, ich habe Zeit. Wie gesagt, zähl alle drei Erfahrungen. Ich sass mal auf einer Schaukel neben meinem Erzfeind. Kannst du nicht mehr mittlerweile den Namen nennen von diesem umgehörigen Erzfeind? Nein, nein, nein, möchte ich nicht.
Borentin.
Ich saß neben meinem Erzfeind und war so fett, dass die Schaukel abgerissen ist.
Aber es klingt so, als wäre es ihm auch nicht gut ergangen.
Oh doch. Weil ich bin ein Anatom und wie die Schaukel aufgebaut ist, dann fällt es doch auch auf ihn drauf, oder nicht?
What?
Du hast schon mal in deinem Leben geschaukelt, deswegen hast du dir irgendwas gebrochen,
einfach wie sie ... Ich weiß nicht, wie man schaukelt. Wie schaukelt man? Sofort kaputt einfach. Nee, also schaukeln, wie ich sie kenne, bestehen aus einem ... Mein Zeigearm! Er muss jetzt damit leben! Ich hab kein Zeigearm. Wir müssen ihn unterstützen. Bestehen aus Stützpfeiler links, Stützpfeiler rechts und oben Balken oben. Ja. Und dann hast du an den Balken so wie so, ja, ich überkompensiere auch mit dem einen Arm, will ich besonders elegant sagen. Wie du auch so direkt 80 Jahre alt bist, einfach so direkt. Naja, da hängen doch Schaukeln, hängen doch an was dran, Leute. Ja, aber nur die Seile ist abgerissen. Ach, Seile ist abgerissen, das hat der Balken beeingestützt. Das war mein Bild. Man muss dazu sagen, er hat Bilder von mir gesehen, wie fett ich damals war.
Also das ist durchaus berechtigt, dass er das denkt.
Nein, von dieser Seite ist abgerissen.
Aber es ist auch schwer als Erzfeind, glaube ich.
Weil als Erzfeind, wenn du deinem Feind wiederum gegenüberstehst, Darth Vader und Luke.
Aber die schaukeln selten nebeneinander.
Also meine Frage ist auch, wie krass kann dein Erzfeind dein Erzfeind sein, wenn ihr nebeneinander schaukelt?
Sind nicht die schlimmsten Feinde die, die uns am nächsten sind?
Nein, nein, meistens nicht.
Aber stell dir vor Darth Vader, hier Luke kommt an auf der Raumstation, geht auf Darth Vader zu,
Vater, ich glaube, es gibt noch Gutes in dir.
Keine Antwort, okay, gut, ich hatte sechs Lichtjahre Zeit, um mir was zu überlegen. Was denn, Luke, mein Sohn, komm mal her, ich weiß, Sorgerechtstreit war schwierig. Willst du dich deinen Helm noch aufsetzen? Ah, klar. Der coole Darth Vader, der den Helm falsch rumhaut. Der coole. Der jugendliche Darth Vader. So trägt man das jetzt, Mama, das ist keine Phase. Nein, in mir ist nichts Gutes drin, Luke. Dann wird es wohl zum Kampf kommen. Und jetzt im dramatischen Moment, die beiden stehen sich gegenüber Erzfeind, zwei Philosophien knallen aufeinander, geht Luke vor und stolpert einfach richtig hart über diesen scheiß Mausroboter auf dem Boden, dann kann Darth Vader auch nicht einfach
anfangen zu lachen. Nein, nein, nein, weil das der schwächste Punkt und du willst ja auch,
vor allem, du willst ja auch einen ebenbürtigen Erzfeind. Ich denke mir, wenn dein Feind ein
Loser ist, der von der Schaukel fällt, dann will ich ja, das macht mehr mich auch als Maurice,
ich habe mal geraten, sehr nah dran, ich kenne mich wie so Wordle, gibt mir richtige Buchstaben, bei Maurice, habe ich richtige Buchstaben getroffen? Ja, ich glaube es ist schwer einen Namen zu finden, wo Maurice nicht drin ist irgendwo. Ist das nicht so eine Regel, dass Maurice überall drinsteckt? Ja, das ist die Regel, das ist die Regel. In jedem Ort ist ein stummer Maurice auch so noch mit drin, aber den spricht man nicht aus. Aber das wäre so jetzt mein Gefühl, der will ja auch einen guten Feind haben. Ja, nee, deswegen, deswegen. Ich glaube, du darfst nicht einfach loslachen und das war auch das Problem in der Situation. Mein Erzfeind konnte das Lachen nicht verbergen und es hat uns fast näher gebracht. Es hat uns näher gebracht dadurch, wenn stell dir vor, Luke stürzt und da auf ihn gefallen ist. Oh scheiße, sorry, Trottel. Ey Mann, es tut mir so leid. Sorry, alles gut, alles gut, was machen diese scheiß Droiden hier, ey. Diese letzten Jahre tun mir so leid, Mann. Sorry, ey. Ey, zum Glück hast du dir den linken Arm gebrochen, sonst wäre begrüssen echt awkward einfach, aber der rechte Arm, wenn der... Nee, eigentlich supergut, weil es halt direkt so ... Ich sehe so aus, als will ich direkt nicht mehr jedem die Hand geben.
Auf dem Wege her, ich dachte, das wäre so ein Münchner Ding, dass man sich direkt die Hand gibt, Fremden, weil ich laufe so rum. Es ist eine andere Distanz. Ach so, hi. Ja. Nee, es ist wie so eine alte Mann-Distanz eigentlich. Ich habe so einen ganz alten Onkel, der immer so ein bisschen weird war, gestorben mittlerweile, aber er hat immer, vielleicht war er so nah an Leuten dran.
Das ist ein bisschen zu nah.
Aber es entwaffelt direkt. Aber es stimmt, es stimmt, das ist ein gutes Ding, also wir müssen uns ja vielleicht langfristig wieder an den Handschlag gewöhnen, je grösser der Winkel, desto weniger mag man die Person.
Also wenn du so auf jemanden zugehst, ganz schlechtes Zeichen, wenn du wirklich so Hand voraus, guten Tag, Guten Tag, wohingegen wenn du so, wirklich so aus der Hüfte, einfach so aus der Hüfte, hey, na, alles klar bei dir, alles gut, aber ist nicht. Aber würdest du sagen, das ist unselbstbewusst, wenn man so auf jemanden zuläuft? Ist auch selbstbewusst aufhand. Das ist halt so die Frage nach der Distanz. Ich glaube, da kannst du dann irgendwie... Okay, wir spielen mal nach Bewerbungsgespräch.
Ich bin Bewerber, du bist Chef.
Okay.
So, und ich muss jetzt sagen, wie ich es empfinde, wie ich meinen neuen Chef empfinde.
Und es ist ein unangenehm langer Gang zum Büro des Chefs.
Ach Gott.
Ja.
Oh Gott.
Und es ist auch kein Bild an der Wand.
Und ich habe nichts zu tun.
Es ist so ein dunkler Gang. Hinten die Tür ist auf, man sieht ihn schon da sitzen. Und ich denke mir jetzt schon, ich werde den Job allein deswegen schon nicht annehmen. Trotzdem gehe ich tapfer hin und sage, ah hallo, Herr Rüdiger. Jesus Christ. Ah, hallo, Herr Tietzer, herzlich willkommen. Ja, okay, war nicht schlecht. Nochmal. War gut. Alter, es war weird, aber ich würde nicht sagen, oh, seltsamer Kerl. Nee, war gut. Zumal der ganze Gang schon ein riesen Red Flag war. Ja. Ich glaube, alleine deswegen wurden Strassen erfunden. Man sagt, die Römer haben die Strassen erfunden, damit sie die Feinde von weit sehen konnten. Aber ich glaube, die eigentliche Idee war, dass die Feinde irgendwann sagen, ach, fuck, der schaut uns die ganze Zeit schon an, Mann. Wir kommen hier aus Gallien. Leute, der hat uns die ganze Zeit angeguckt. Quintus schaut uns die ganze Zeit an. Es gibt so Phasen. Der winkt seit Bonn. Ja. Aber Moment, die haben, sorry, die haben die Strassen gebaut, damit man die Feinde sieht? What? Normalerweise hast du ja so Schlengelpfade. Aber Strassen sind jetzt auch in den wenigsten Momenten sich nur straxen, also außer Flugschleisen. Nee, die Strassen ist schon gerade. Und so ist halt das Problem, du stehst auf. Florentinville, Strassen sind schon gerade. Wir können es jetzt nicht überprüfen. Oder wollen wir kurz rausgehen? Hat jeder eine Jacke dabei? Ich kenne die Strasse in München, ich bin hier aufgewachsen, ich kann mich hier aus. Aber es ist so, normalerweise... Wer wohnt in einer komplett geraden Strasse von euch, wo man Feinde sieht? Ja, der Stefan Flügel jetzt natürlich wieder auf seiner Seite. Wo man Feinde sieht. Florentin Flügel ist auf der anderen Seite.
Nee, ich habe keine Autorität. Mutter!
Mein Problem ist, warum sitzt Mutter auf dem Stefan Flügel?
Weil ich sie ... Wir sind nicht ... Stopp!
Gemischtes Hakt. Stopp! Stopp! Da ist die Grenze. Bis dahin und nicht weiter.
Sag mal, angenommen, du wärst richtig sauer, Stefan. Angenommen, Stefan, du wärst richtig sauer.
Ich hau auf den Tisch.
Angenommen, du wärst richtig sauer und du hättest die Schnauze gestrichen voll.
Schatz, ich hab dich doch gerade mit dem gesehen, mit dem Gregor. Ich hab dich doch da draußen gesehen. Was denn Schatz? Ich hab dir gesagt, ich geb dir noch eine Chance. Schatz, hi, erst mal. Schatz, ich hab dir gesagt, bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Ich hab dir noch eine Chance gegeben. Dann noch die zweite, im Urlaub. Das war eine Ausnahme, habe ich gesagt. Da war ich weird. Da habe ich dich in die Arme getrieben von Fernandes. Dann habe ich gesagt, bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Es tut mir leid. Okay. Passt schon. Die Wut kann auch nicht so hochkommen. Nein, bis hier hier. Aber angenommen, du hättest die Nase gestrichen voll. Bis wohin hättest du die Nase gestrichen? Nein, ich hab's... Bis wohin steht's dir? Ich steh knietief in Scheiße, mit Hüft hoch. Ja. Aber mir steht's nicht bis hier, weil das ist nicht so geil zu sein.
Und als du mich das letzte Mal gesehen hast, wie gross war ich da? Und das ist der Rest des Abends. Wir müssen das ausnutzen, wir müssen das ausnutzen, der perfekte Stefan, der Unzerstörbare ist endlich mal am Boden, jetzt müssen wir auch auf ihn drauf treten. Du hast mich, hinter der Bühne hast du mich Ibu-Prophet genannt, weil ich auch so viel Ibu bin, um diesen Abend irgendwie über die Bühne zu bekommen, über die Manege zu bekommen, dass ich sozusagen der Ibu-Prophet bin. Es gab zum Glück noch ein bisschen Elefantenbetäubungsmittel in dem Schrank, da konnten wir uns doch Medieten frei. Das solltest du doch nicht sagen. Aber jetzt zum Thema Schlüsselbein. Ich bin kein Anatom, wie gesagt. Haben wir denn Anatome da? Gar keinen. Überhaupt gar keinen Anatom da. Wow. Nicht schlecht. Oder ist es peinlich? Ich habe eben ein Publikum gesehen, wo die Freundin so gesagt hat, so, hey, du bist doch Anatom. Und er hat gesagt, nein. Sprich mich nicht an. Nicht mehr seit dem Vorfall, Schatz, erinnere mich nicht daran, ich habe eines der 16 Beine miteinander verwechselt. Also wie gesagt, ich bin kein Anatom, aber jetzt mal nur von der Wortbedeutung, würde ich sagen, das Schlüsselbein, recht wichtig, oder? Also es fühlt sich so an, als sei es sehr wichtig. Es spielt sich so auf in meinem Körper gerade, weil es gebrochen ist und die ganze Zeit Aua schreit, als wäre es etwas, was man dringend reparieren sollte, wie ein richtiges Bein. Ja. Es ist noch ein bisschen so eine Drama Queen, habe ich das Gefühl, diese Knochen. Ja, boah, das Schlüsselbein ist nervt. Ja, weil der nicht so wirklich, weil wenn du halt auch ein Skelett siehst, das Schlüsselbein ist recht fixiert. Du kannst da nicht grosse Kunststücke machen oder sowas oder das rausfahren oder so oder wie so einen kleinen Finger bewegen, sondern das ist einfach nur so ein fixer Knochen. Okay, also nochmal ganz kurz für alle, weil ich weiß, wie gesagt, gar keine Anatomen anwesend, nicht jeder hat Wikipedia hat Wikipedia zur Hand, was genau das ist das Schlüsselbein nochmal. Das ist der grosse Knochen, der hervorschaut, eigentlich bei jedem Menschen, oben an der Schulter, der vom Hals Richtung Schulter starrt. Da würde ich sagen, zur Vorbeugung wollen wir alle mal schön unser Schlüsselbein kreisen. Demen. Schön mal alle im Raum, ja, auch du, ja auch du, alle schön, mal alle gemeinsam. Nein, ihr kreist mit den Schultern. Nein, nein, nicht die Schulter, es ist zwischen Schulter und Hals. Dieser eine Punkt und den mal schön alle, man sieht's nicht, aber man spürt's. Oh ja, oh, oh, das ist ganz schön anstrengend.
Fuck yes.
Das ist Workout, das kann jeder zuhause mitmachen, egal wo ihr gerade seid, damit euch nicht
das passiert, was Stefan Tietze passiert.
Ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, diese Story ist sehr vielseitig und so, sehr komplex,
es sind viele Dinge passiert, ich bin nicht stolz drauf, ich bin nicht der Held, liebe
Stefan Seite, ich bin nicht der Held in dieser Geschichte, es gibt keine Helden in dieser Geschichte, es soll mehr als Lehre für euch dienen, das nicht aufzumachen. Gibt es eine Lektion, gibt es eine Moral von der Geschichte? Die Lektion ist Fahrt nicht mit fucking E-Rollern. Ah, okay. Das ist die Lektion. Okay. Ich sehe, okay, der alte Fluch der Elektromobilität weilt also immer noch auf dir. Ich war der grösste Verfechter, wir erinnern uns an Boosted-Bot, Stefan, wir erinnern uns an die E-Scooter-Zeit, wo ich meinte, das gibt es ja auch in Köln. Wir erinnern uns an 50 kmh, Stefan. Nein, wir erinnern uns an die Reihen in den Reihenphase, wo wir unsere Hörer dazu ermutigt haben, die Dinge in den Reihen zu werfen. Genau, mit Erfolg, mit Erfolg. Und jetzt falle ich mit diesem Ding hin. Also du hast nichts gelernt. Du hast nichts vom Boosterboard gelernt. Ich behaupte, ich war ein unglaublich guter Rollerfahrer. Ich würde behaupten, ich war ein Top-1% der Rollerfahrer in Köln.
Ich will nicht für euch sprechen. Aber reden wir jetzt von so einem Vespa-Roller?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir reden schon von den nervigen, erbärmlichen.
Wir reden von dem kleinen 20 kmh, zwei Stöcke, aneinandergeschraubt, mit zwei Rädern drunter und los geht die Fahrt. Davon reden wir. So, und die sollte man eh schon nicht benutzen, sondern man sollte sie noch weniger benutzen, wenn man vielleicht was getrunken hat. Oh! Wie gesagt, wie gesagt, spart euch die Bu-Rufe. Ich habe gesagt, es gibt keinen Helden in der Geschichte und dann kann man alles sagen. Und das von dir, der so oft Don't Drink and Drive betont hat. Du hast so oft Don't Drink and Drive. Meine Kampagne, ne? Ja, das hast du so oft gesagt. Nee, ich habe es glaube ich nicht so cool gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, trinkt einfach nicht, wenn ihr zu fahren versucht. Wie ist der neue Satz? Ich habe ja gehört, man soll nicht Don't drink and drive sagen. Don't drink while you're driving. Der klingt wirklich wie von einem schlechteren Autoren. Moment, was war noch mal die Begründung? Don't drink and drive, don't drink while you're driving. Das konnte man irgendwie falsch verstehen. Ich glaube, das war irgendwie, wenn man die Buchstaben anders anordnet, ist es so eine satanistische Botschaft. Don't drink and thus drive. Okay.
Alles klar, also egal welche.
Don't drive thy car.
Diese ganze Kampagne ist also jetzt offiziell komplett gescheitert.
Stefan Tietze entschied sich dazu, zu drinken und zu driben, gleichzeitig.
Also man darf ja ein bisschen was, ich habe lustigerweise vor zwei Wochen
wurde ich angehalten, nachts vom Polizisten, und ich musste pusten auf so einem Roller, und da hatte ich auch schon ein bisschen was getrunken, man darf ja auch ein bisschen was trinken und dann fahren, weil nicht zu viel trinken ist, wie beim Auto, ich glaube, oder wie beim Fahrrad sogar, da darf man vielleicht noch mehr trinken, weiß ich nicht genau, vielleicht ist es hier auch wieder anders. Haben wir Alkoholiker im Raum? Haben wir Leute, die es brauchen? Und bin ich, dachte ich mir, und vielleicht hat mich diese Polizeikontrolle, die ich bestanden habe, auch so ein bisschen ermutigt. Ich will nicht sagen, dass die Polizei schuld war, ich sage nur, das ist die Reihenfolge der Ereignisse, sondern bin ich nachts, wollte ich nach Hause kommen und dann habe ich, es war ein Boat, das war die sehr billigste Rollermarke und man sieht es, also man merkt es, weil alles ist ein bisschen instabiler und so, das will ich nur zwei Stöcker mit. Und hattest du den Helm dabei und deine Schulzerpanzer und alles? Nein, okay. So, und dann machst du halt, wenn du nachts diese Roller entsperrst, und das hatte ich noch nie, musste ich einen Test machen, ob ich zugetrunken bin, diesen Roller zu fahren. Wirklich? Daran erinnere ich mich noch. Kleiner, kleiner Hint, wohin diese Story noch geht. Kleiner Hint, dann habe ich so ein Spiel gemacht, das war ein Reaktionstest. Irgendwie drücke, wenn, und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, was da zu sehen war, wenn der Bildschirm grün wird oder sowas. Bist du dir sicher, dass du nicht im Suff einfach Angry Birds aufgemacht hast? Vielleicht habe ich... Wie viele Level kommen da noch? Sonne geht auf. Ich muss Candy Crush bis zu welchem Level spielen? Ja, das war so ein Test und ich weiß noch, dass diese App gesagt hat, ja, fahr. Weißt du was? Fahr, fahr, bitte. Du hast den doppelte Geschwindigkeit-Bust freigeschaltet, du bist so nüchtern. Du kannst umsonst fahren für ein Jahr. It's insane. Niemals war jemand so gut, so habe ich in Erinnerung. Also ich war sehr gut in diesem Ding. So, dann konnte ich fahren, Bolt war freigeschaltet und ich bin damit gefahren. So, und jetzt, ab da hört mein Gedächtnis auch. Ich bin gefahren und ich konnte am nächsten Morgen die Strecke sehen, wie ich gefahren bin, weil die App sagt einem ja in der Rechnung, wie die Strecke war, die man gefahren hat. Das ist ja genial, ja. Sehr guter, may I say, sehr gut gewählter Heimweg. Schnellste Strecke, schnellste Strecke, toll. So, dann hört die Fahrt auf, im Köln am Mediapark. Sagt euch jetzt nichts vielleicht für ein paar Leute zuhause interessant, da hört die abrupt auf.
Okay, man muss dazu sagen, deine Ex-Freundin wohnt da, also von daher.
Ja, ja, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht wichtig.
Okay, ne gut.
Es ist für manche Leute interessant, aber es ist ja jetzt egal.
Nur zur Einordnung.
Da hört die auf.
So, und dann, das Einzige, was ich noch weiss, ab dem Moment, wo ich dieses Spiel gespielt habe, wo ich bewiesen habe, dass ich nicht betrunken war, war, dass ich plötzlich an einem ganz anderen Ort stand, ohne Roller, ohne Kopfhörer, weil ich bin mit Kopfhörern gefahren und habe Musik gehört, wie ich immer fahre, auch nicht gut, sollte man auch nicht. Wow. Sollte man nicht machen. Nein, nein, big no no. Dein Arm hat jetzt so einen eigenen Willen und versucht die verschleckten Dinge. Nein, nein, nein, nie wieder. Und dann weiß ich noch, dann stand ich plötzlich da und ich wusste, und das war unglaublich gruselig, nicht mehr, wo ich den Abend verbracht habe, was gerade passiert war. Ich habe nur gemerkt, meine ganze linke Seite zudem tut extrem weh,
ich habe ein bisschen Blut am Kopf und ich wusste nicht mehr, woher ich kam.
Und das war unglaublich gruselig.
So, am nächsten Tag habe ich dann geguckt, was ist denn da überhaupt passiert, wo bin ich dann langgefahren,
habe aber gemerkt, ich habe sehr zügig die alte Rollerfahrt beendet.
Das heißt, und das beruhigt mich sehr, selbst im desolatesten Zustand bin ich so sehr Sparfuchs, dass ich direkt meine Rollermiete beende. Weil ich habe viele Freunde, wo das dann ein Riesending ist, dass man das vergessen hat und dann zahlt man schon mal 60 Euro. Damit verdient ihr ihr Geld. Das ist das ganze Businessmodell. Genau, richtig. Und die Fahrt hat 1,33 Euro gekostet und wurde sofort beendet. Das heißt, ich hatte irgendwo einen furchtbaren Unfall, wohl, bin dann orientierungslos weitergelaufen, habe in der Zeit wohl diese Fahrt beendet, sehr gruselig. So, und jetzt bin ich stolz darauf, meine Mails am nächsten Morgen, meine True-Crime-Recherche ergaben, dass es da noch eine zweite Rollerfahrt gab. Oh, das ist jetzt das Ende von Folge eins, wo man merkt so, holy shit, es geht noch viel weiter. Nein, nein hat er nicht. Abspann. Fuck, Schatz, wir gucken weiter. Ja, komm, eine noch. Eine noch. Eine noch. Ist auch nur noch eine. Naja, und dann gibt es noch eine andere Fahrt. So, und das Problem ist, was mich ein bisschen noch, ja, Sorgen macht, ist, da sind 34 Minuten zwischen. Und diese andere Fahrt, die beginnt jetzt auch nicht da, wo die andere Fahrt aufgehört hat, aber sie ist auch nicht 34 Minuten zu Fuss weg. Ich weiß noch, dass ich orientierungslos da stand und dachte mir, was ist gerade gerade passiert, woher komme ich, warum tut mir alles weh, wollte dann auch immer nach Hause, hab dann einen anderen Roller genommen, wieder von da, schnellste Route nach Hause, wieder beendet bei mir zu Hause, alles gut. Das heisst, es könnte sein, dass du diese Strecke zwischen erster Fahrt und zweiter Fahrt nicht laufend zurückgelegt hast. Es könnte sein, dass du gestürzt bist, den Roller gesperrt hast und dann dich auf dem Boden rollend, daher kommen vielleicht die Verletzungen, dich rollend weiterbewegt hast, bis du gemerkt hast, Stopp, ich habe Beine. Jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder, wozu die gut waren und bis weitergelaufen. Ich konnte mich nicht erinnern, wo ich gerade war, mit wem ich unterwegs war, es war mega gruselig. Und Hermann, in der zweiten Roller war auch keine Erinnerung mehr, ausser dass ich dann irgendwann zu Hause aufgewacht bin, morgens mit extremen Schmerzen und dachte mir, holy shit, was war gestern denn passiert. Und also ich habe nicht so viel getrunken. Ich habe generell noch nie in meinem Leben eine Gedächtnislücke durch Alkohol gehabt. Und das war gut, jetzt kann man sagen, das erste Mal. Aber ich bin halt aufgewacht auf einem blutenden Kissenlücke durch Alkohol gehabt und das war, gut, jetzt kann man sagen, aber ich bin halt aufgewacht auf einem blutenden Kissen und dachte mir, vielleicht war da das Problem und der Grund für diesen kleinen Blackout. Ja, oder das Kissen halt geblutet, man weiß es nicht, was in diesem modernen Kissen drin ist, du hast ja auch so Hightech-Kissen. Ja, Kissen geblutet. Mit echten Enten drin.
Kann sein.
Was heißt Daunen? Ich weiß es nicht. Was ist das? Sie sind, ich will es nochmal wiederholen, Sie sind bei die Hülle der Löwen, okay, nur das Wissen. Ja, natürlich. Und Ihre Produktidee ist ein Daunenkissen mit echten Gänsen drin? Ja, wissen Sie, das Problem an Daunen ist, wenn man sie der Ente entreißt oder der Gans oder dem Fährich oder dem Fasad. Ja, dem Fährich, wir alle kennen den Fasad oder den fast ausgestorbenen Fährich. Ich weiß, wegen meiner vielen Fasanenkissen. Die ersten zwei Monate super flauschig-weich, nach einer gewissen Zeit schlecht krumm-bröselig. Deswegen unsere Idee, wir packen den Fasan direkt rein und verschicken das Ganze. Und der lebt noch oder ist tot? Nee, der lebt. Der lebt. Der hat so eine kleine Kette von so Zuckerkügelchen um den Hals und damit kann der so richtig ein Jahr überleben. Kann der ein Jahr überlegen. Wir haben das genau dosiert und der hat ja einen ganz langen Hals. Und da passt wahnsinnig viele von diesen Zuckerperlen dran.
Und was wollen Sie für diese Idee haben?
Sechs Millionen Euro.
Für wie viele Prozent Ihres Unternehmens?
Vier.
Wir haben einen Deal.
Okay.
Und dann eine Woche später, Chef, von den vierhundertsechzigtausend produzierten Kissen haben wir nur ein einziges verkauft. Bevor er sich in der Zeit, die sich in der Zeit, die sich in der Zeit, die. Stefan Tietze in Köln. Mach den Lern dicht. Okay. Aber jetzt kann es sein. Also blutig aufgewacht. Was war dein erster Gedanke? Also hast du... Scheisse, scheisse, scheisse. Und dann erst mal Check, also welche Körperöffnung ist es oder was passiert? Ich bin interessanterweise zuerst Telefonnummern durchgegangen, die ich auswendig kenne. Okay. Weil ich dachte... Also 11 88 0, 110, 112, 116, 116, 116, 1, 6, 1, 6, die Kartennummer, die Gifffnummer … Die Kartennummer, die Gifffnummer … 88, die Oma und 0 … Scheiße. Aber Moment mal, sorry, ganz kurze Frage. Wie stehst du auf dem Bett aus, dass du dein Kissen siehst? Ich habe das Story verkürzt erzählt. Ich glaube, wenn ich, ich würde gar nicht merken, dass mein Kissen blutig ist, oder? Ich bin Bauchschläfer. Bei mir ist es so ein... Ach, du bist direkt in deiner Blutlache aufgewacht. Du wachst auf und es ist direkt so ein... Mit so einem blubbernden Geräusch. Ja, wie so ein Tarantino-Shot eigentlich, so jemand, der in seinem eigenen Blut und dann so schrecklich. Du bist wirklich Bauchschläfer. Es war ganz wenig, ja, ich bin Bauchschläfer. Bauch, aber auch Seitenschläfer. Und eigentlich bin ich alles, das ist boring, das ist boring zu erzählen. Man nennt dich auch das Grillhuhn, einfach die ganze Nacht. Ich hab, es ist nicht so, dass es so ein ruckartiges Wenden ist, sondern ich drehe mich konstant über die gesamte Nacht mit einer konstanten Geschwindigkeit. Aber wie schläfst du? Die ganze Nacht. Ganz langsam. Das ist die gesündeste Art zu schlafen, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Und so langsam, dass wenn man nur kurz hinguckt, denkt man nicht, dass ich mich bewege. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und dann guckt man nochmal hin und denkt, rechts rum. Aber du ziehst halt auch langsam die Decke weg. Ja, das ist nassig. Also wirklich hardcore nassig. Und dann wie bei so einem Tesafilm, dann flappt es immer so über das Ende. Aber nur einmal alle zwölf Stunden. Wie schläfst du? Nee, schönen Seitenschläfer. Aber ich bin wirklich der unruhigste Schläfer der Welt. Ich weiß nicht, weil Seitenschläfer heißt ja, du bist auf der einen Seite und dann auf der anderen Seite. Das ist, glaube ich, so ein Ding, wo ich mal so einen Realitätscheck bräuchte. Wie lange ist der Abstand zwischen links und rechts, weil bei mir ist er unter einer Minute. Also wirklich, wirklich ungelogen. Ich lege, linke Seite denkt mir, boah, das ist es nicht, oder? Das geht besser, ich kriege das... Nee, nee, das wird jetzt schon langweilig. Einmal noch. Vielleicht fühlst du wirklich die Drehbewegung cooler, als dann an einem Ort zu verweilen. Du willst eher den Campingurlaub als die Ferienwohnung, weißt du? Vor allem, ich drehe mich so um, dass im Verlauf der Drehbewegung mein gesamter Körper zu einem Zeitpunkt vollständig in der Luft ist. Also ihr kennt ja alle den Unterschied zwischen Rennen und Walken. Der Unterschied ist, dass beim Rennen zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt beide... Immer, genau. Und beim Walken hast du... Be, ja genau, so rennt jeder Mensch, genau. Beide Beine. Ja, das ist wirklich Lexikon-Eintrag für Rennen. Das ist Rennen. Ja. Also die letzte Reihe so, fuck, echt? Ich mach's immer falsch. Und das ist auch so, bei mir ist es so, dass es einen Zeitpunkt gibt, wo ich wirklich in diesen ... Bewegungen einmal komplett ... Das zwar lustig, weil ich bilde mir ein, ich habe irgendwann mal, und das ist ja manchmal so, wenn man sich Dinge bewusst macht, vergisst man, wie sie existieren, wie es funktioniert. Ja, absolut. So etwas wie, du gehst komisch, und seitdem geht man dann weird. Ja, gar nicht. Weil es gibt auch irgendwie so, es meinte glaube ich mal irgendein berühmter Tennisspieler, ich habe vergessen, wer, es gab einen anderen Tennisspieler, der immer dann zu allen Leuten hingegang ist,
so vorm Match und gesagt hat, so machst du den Aufschlag, so hältst du den Schläger.
Interessant. Und er meinte, das ist super schlimm, wenn man dann hinterfragt, wie man den Schläger hält und das ganze Automatismusgehirn zerstört. Ach du, hältst du ihn in der rechten Hand oder was? Krass, okay, cool, du dein Ding. Sechshundert zu null geworden einfach. So zählt man beim Tennis. Wir haben einfach weiter gemacht. Fuck it. Ne, genau. Wo kamen wir her? Gehen. Wie man schläft. Genau, und ich habe mir überlegt, weil ich habe mir irgendwann bewusst gemacht, wie drehe ich mich eigentlich, weil ich mir am besten Ich kann mir das erste Bild nicht vorstellen, wie man schläft, dass ich weiter schläft. Genau, so, und ich habe mir überlegt, weil ich habe mir irgendwann mal bewusst gemacht, wie drehe ich mich eigentlich, weil ich mir am besten will, wenn ich mich vorstellen kann, wie man sich dreht, also was für Muskelgruppen man ansteuert, um sich zu drehen. Und seitdem bewege ich mich so seltsam und irgendwie ein Bein wird hochgedreht und dann wird Schwung geholt und so rüber. Das ist mega weird. Wie drehst du dich? Dreh ich mal unter und leg ich mal kurz auf die Bühne, leg ich mal ganzne. Das Ding ist, ich drehe mich über die Beine. Ich drehe mich komplett über die Beine, und zwar die Scherentechnik.
Und zwar lege ich so im Bett. Und dann, wenn ich sage, jetzt ist Zeit zu drehen, mache ich die Beine auf.
Genau, ja.
Und durch die, ja, ne, je breiter die Beine sind, desto grösser ist der Hebel und dann ist es ganz leicht.
Es ist super leicht. Es ist wirklich, es ist total leicht.
Wobei, also, Lifehack, insane.
Aber du liegst nicht so, wie ich denke, also weil ich interpretiere Leichenschläfer.
Wir sind uns nicht mal einig, was ein Seitenschläfer ist. Nein, mein Becken kippt auch. Ich liege ja so da. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht hinlegen. Nochmal, wo ist das Bett jetzt? Ich bin das Bett. Ich bin das Bett. Sei endlich mal mein Bett. So, pass auf, so. Und du drehst dich ja nur so. Was ist das jetzt? Was ist das jetzt? Was bist du jetzt, die Wand? Ich bin das Bett. Okay, pass auf, also du drehst dich ja quasi so. Gute Nacht, Stefan.
So rum. Schlaf gut, Stefan. Bett. Wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder. Ich muss diese der Hülle der Löwenkäufe sein lassen. Ich warte auf dich, die Nacht. Ich muss mein Kissen kurz richten. Aber das ist seitlich für dich. Nein, nein, nein. Ich warte, bis sie aufhören. Bis sie endlich aufhören zu können. Pass auf, und du legst hier quasi dann nur mal von da auf so. Aber meins ist dann komplett so. Lass uns über die Hüfte reden. Die Hüfte ist Kontaktpunkt. Gerade ist sie... Nee, das ist doch...
Nee, gerade bei dir ist sie ja immer so, bei dir ist sie immer gerade.
Hä, aber ich bin doch das Bett, nein, ich bin ja so an deiner Hosentasche.
So bin ich.
So bin ich jetzt.
Ja.
So bin ich dann, wenn ich auf der Seite schlafe, ist so mein Becken.
Was, ist das Problem?
Aber was ist der Unterschied zu mir, genau so nicht...
Ja, mach mal vor, dann bin ich dein Bett.
Okay.
Na, ich bin so einfach.
Nein, gerade auf dem Boden war es so nicht so.
Ich behaupte, dass du dich mit deiner Taktik nicht mit dem Becken bewegen kannst. Hauch mich mal an, Stefan. Ein Kumpel hat mal gesagt, er hat dann versucht, Zeit zu schinden, indem er vorgetäuscht hat, nicht zu wissen, wie man dieses Bläschen puste kann. Man muss ein bisschen länger durchhalten, um sich ein paar Minuten zu erkauffen.
Und hat das so daneben gepustet.
Dadurch wirkte er sehr nicht an.
Wie lange hast du das gemacht, dass du dachtest, es hat einen Effekt auf deinen Alkoholgehalt?
So, mach das vernünftig.
Für mich ist auch sechste Stunde, Freunde. Wenn wir das jetzt nicht verstehen, verstehen wir es nicht.
Uiuiui.
Nein, nicht, mach nicht.
Nee, aber die haben einen Lehn.
Schlüsselbeine brechen leicht.
Warum legst du dich da drauf? Du kannst dich auf die ... Nein, nein, nein, dafür habe ich Trädit. Die haben Lehnen! Ist dir jetzt aufgefallen? Vor allem, ich denke die ganze Zeit inzwischen an unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen zu Hause, die sich fragen, was ist da passiert. Gute Nacht, Schatz. Schatz, Nacht. Was hat dich für eine Beziehung? Nee, ich schlaf gut so, kein Problem. Nee, ich hab genug Platz. Nee, ist in Ordnung so. Gute Nacht. Aber jetzt dreh dich mal mit deiner Taktik. Nee, ich mache gar nichts mehr, ich schlaf hier. Aber so seitlich. Ja, ja genau. Wo sind meine Arme? Aber so kannst du dich ja nicht drehen mit deiner, ich spreize meine Beine Taktik und nutze dann den, wie willst du dich so drehen? Die anderen. Ja genau, nein, oh Gott. Oh shit, ah Hilfe. Ja, weil wir haben alle geklatscht und gejubelt, weil wir dachten, wow, insane, wie man so schnell effizient sich drehen kann, wie ein Spiegelei, aber du brauchst ja so ein Ja.
Ja, ist aber auch keine Realsituation jetzt gerade.
Das stimmt.
Ich muss mich jetzt unironisch mal kurz hinlegen, hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun.
So, jetzt rede ich mal mit deiner Taktik.
Bein nach hinten, rechtes Bein, hinten, so, zack, hoch drüber. Oh! Das ist so schnell. Die Nacht ist in kürzester Zeit um. Nee, ist doch noch gut. Oh, jetzt schwitze ich. Ist doch noch gut. Die muss ich auch noch in den Stuhlraum tragen heute. Du musst ihn auch nicht mal wegtragen. Ich weiss nicht, warum du den immer da hinten hin trägst. So jedenfalls bin ich dann auch mit dem blutigen Kissen, das war nicht so toll, da war ein bisschen Blut am Kissen, aber so, da ich dachte, Jesus Christ. Und das heisst, dein Schlüsselbein hat direkt aus dem Schlüssel einfach direkt rausgeblutet, oder was? Ne, ich hatte keine, bis auf die Schürfwunde unter meinem Kopf hatte ich keine Wunde offen an meinem Körper, nur extreme Schmerzen am Flüsselbein und an der Hüfte und am Bein. Und dann habe ich gedacht, dann habe ich eine Freundin angerufen und hat mich relativ schnell ins Krankenhaus gebracht, wo ich dann am Empfang gesagt habe, da muss man ja wirklich, obwohl es jetzt nicht so ein Notfallnotfall war. Ich wollte gerade sagen, hättest du das nicht alleine noch geschafft? Ich bin mit gebrochenem Zeh noch selber zum Fussarzt gefahren und wieder zurück, weil ich ein Vollidiot bin und meine Karte nicht dabei hatte. Aber es ist... Und du einfach, oh mein Schlüsselbein... Ja, wo du dann bei der Künstlersozialkaste angerufen hast, um herauszufinden, dass es nicht eine Versicherung ist, wo man sagt, von so einem Menschen will ich vielleicht dies nicht in Frage gestellt bekommen, wie ich mit meinem gebrochenen Schlüsselbein und meiner Schürfung am Kopf umgehe. Aber ja, ich hätte es auch selber mit mir verhandeln können. Bin dann jedenfalls zur Aufnahme gegangen und dann musste man sich da anmelden und dann habe ich versucht, einen Scherz zu machen, weil dann musste ich auch schon den Unfallhergang an der Anmeldung erzählen und habe gesagt, ich bin da am Kopf gefallen, kann gefallen, kann mich nicht an den Unfallhergang erinnern. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, okay, unterschreiben Sie einfach hier und ist das noch Ihre richtige Adresse? Und ich habe einen Gag gemacht, weiss ich nicht. Und mit dem gelangweiltesten Halt-dein-Mau-Gesicht hat sie mich angeguckt, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, also richtig. Oh Gott! Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ja, richtig, sorry, sorry.
Und dann dachte ich gesagt, ja, ja, richtig, sorry, sorry. Und dann dachte ich mir, total dumm, da dann so Gags zu machen, die suggerieren, dass es mir ja noch einigermaßen gut geht. Ich wollte aber auch nicht, dass sie denken, dass ich jetzt denke, ich habe das größte Problem der Welt und muss sofort rankommen, sondern dachte mir, da sind bestimmt Leute mit schlimmeren Problemen, dann sollen die einfach rank Da hast du so gefühlt, dass ich so vier Stunden da saß. Aber finde ich spannend,
ich hätte es andersrum gemacht, ich hätte viel wehleidiger getan, weil ich denke immer so, wenn
man die Wunde nicht sieht, also du läufst da rein, da hat jemand einen Pfeil im Kopf, so eine
Bärenpfanne am Bein und du so, es ist ein innerer Schaden und ich hätte wirklich da richtig auf
die Dramatube gedrückt und einfach wäre da so Kriech und Reise, Mutter, Mutter!
Ja, ich habe mich hier verletzt.
Also du hättest eigentlich den gleichen Gag gemacht mit, ich kann mich nicht erinnern an meine Adresse, hättest du es nur ernst gemeint.
Ja, ich hätte das viel mehr drauf gedrückt, aber gut.
Aber es war wirklich da, es war wirklich, es war wie bei so einer Simpsons-Szene mit Leuten mit Pfeilen im Kopf. Also es gab Hundebiss, war vor mir dran, Hundebiss. Der Hund sitzt so daneben so, he he he, er habe mich erwischt hier, ha ha ha, schöne Notaufnahme. Aber ich fand es so gut, weil dann kam plötzlich ein Arzt raus und hat den Namen aufgerufen und dann kam der nicht, dann hat er so einen Arzthelfer hervorgerufen und gesagt, wo ist ein Hundebiss? Und dann meinte er, Hundebiss ist gerade auf dem Klo. Und dann so, ja okay, wen nehmen wir denn dann? Ja, Augenbraue. Ja, wenn Hundebiss auf dem Klo ist, nehmen wir Augenbraue. Augenbraue, und dann ist eine Frau aufgestanden und in den Raum gegangen. Da merkt man, was wirklich zählt. Du hast Hundebiss, Augenbraue, Schlüsselbein. Du hast dir das coolste T-Shirt der Welt bestellt, aber die Leute nennen dich Augenbraue, vergiss das einfach. Ja, da war Hundebiss dran und dann kam Notfall rein, also eigentlich war es eine coole Samstagsbeschäftigung, weil man viele Sachen sieht, die spannend sind. Ja, ist das wie bei Schlangenbissen, dass man den Hund mitbringen soll? Um zu zeigen, ach es war ein Golden Retriever, dann ist es egal. Ich weiss nicht, dass wenn man von der Schlange gebissen wurde, muss man die Schlange mitbringen und da einfach so auf die Theke knallen, so hier, habt ihr ihn. Für das Gegengift, für das richtige Gegengift. Ja, für das Gegengift. Beim Golden Retriever muss man nehmen. Wie bitte? Beim Golden Retriever, was für ein Gegengift? Gegen Golden Retriever, da muss man nur einmal kurz weggucken, dann sind die schon genug bestraft. Okay, Chihuahua? Das ist schon genug Bestrafung dafür. Chihuahua-Amphetamine einfach, volle Lotter einfach, kannst du komplett vergessen. Sehr gut. Ja, dann kam, dann kam er dran, und dann wäre ich eigentlich dran gewesen, aber dann kam ein Notfall rein. Ach, boring. Und dann kam nämlich auf der Horroranblick Motorradunfall, haben sie gesagt, also dann war Augenbraue, Hundebiss und Motorradunfall kam rein und sein Kopf wurde mit so Schrauben fixiert, das war schrecklich anzugucken und dann habe ich gedacht, es ist nicht der Ort für Gags. Es ist nicht der Ort, jetzt aufzustehen und zu sagen, ja, aber ich war ja eigentlich vor dem Herrn da. Okay, ich sehe, ja, ich sehe. Dann wäre ich rausgeflogen in dem Moment. Hab's mir verkniffen.
Das ist doch Deutschland, Comedy-Entwicklungsland Deutschland. Da kann man nicht immer so einen Gag machen. Habe ich mir dann verkniffen und dann kam ich dann irgendwann dran und habe dem dann eine furchtbare Geschichte erzählen müssen. Und dann sind die schon so ein bisschen angepisst wegen E-Scooter-Accident, weil ich glaube, Ich glaube, dann haben auch alle Ärzte inzwischen bestätigt, seitdem es diese E-Scooter gibt, haben die so viel mehr zu tun, weil Idioten wie ich damit auf die Fresse fliegen nachts. Aber du wusstest zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht, was los ist. Also da hätte jetzt auch gebrochene Hüfte sein können. Genau. Oder alles, aber du hattest schon eine Idee, also... Ja, ich habe gesagt, es ist schon mein Schlüsselbein durch. Also du hattest tatsächlich das Wort Schlüsselbein schon im Kopf. Ich habe gesagt, und mein Schlüsselbein tut weh, es ist wahrscheinlich gebrochen. Wie konntest du das so genau benennen? Mit meinem Doktorhaus wissen. Okay. Ich habe gesagt, intubieren, intubieren. Und du hast nicht davor gegoogelt und auf Wikipedia den lateinischen Namen des Knochens rausgesucht, um schlau zu wirken? Ähm, Claviatus. Ich habe da so ein leichtes Ziel in meinem Klaviatus Maximus.
Ja, und dann musste ich zum Röntgen,
weil auch meine Hüfte ist mega angeschlagen,
da musste die auch geröntgt werden,
und dann haben die erst mein Schlüsselbein geröntgt und mir so eine Bleischürze für die Weichteile angezogen,
nur um die dann beim zweiten Bild wegzunehmen.
Als Strafe.
Dieses Röntgengerät runterzufahren auf Schritthöhe. Dann haben die gesagt, haben sie da irgendwie so Metall, da hatte ich immer in der Joggyhose so Metall, da musste ich mir eine Hose noch ausziehen. Also die haben, erst habe ich eine Beihugschürze getragen, damit die dann quasi voll drauf halten konnten beim zweiten Bild. Ja, also Hüfte, alles gut, generell alles gut, Schürf runter am Koffoffer, der sich anguckt, meinte, reicht ihm nicht für ein CC wegen Strahlenbelastung, bla bla bla, und ja, Schlüsselbein ist leider gebrochen. Und ja, deswegen muss ich übermorgen operiert werden am Schlüssel. Ja, eine dumme Geschichte, right? Moment, wenn du übermorgen operiert wirst, heißt das, dass das, was du gerade hast, überhaupt völlig egal ist, dass es nichts bringt? Nein, nein, ich habe auch gesagt, ja, Dienstag bin ich in München, das ist alles ein bisschen doof jetzt vom Timing her, der hat gesagt, ja, das kann ich auch nicht ändern, dann habe ich gesagt, und dann meinte er ja, aber das Ding ist, und dann meinte er ja, ich gucke mal, ob es durch die Haut sticht, also ob das eine Möglichkeit ist, wenn ich mal irgendwann eine weirden Bewegung mache, dass dann irgendwie so ein Ding rauskommt, ist keine Möglichkeit, aber es ist schrecklich, es ist einfach schrecklich. Naja, jetzt habe ich so ein gebrochenes Ding da. Es ist wie so ein Petzspender, wo du den Arm so zurücknimmst, kommt da einfach so das Schlüsselbein, so ein Blutspender eigentlich. Aber nochmal, Schlüsselbein ist es was Längliches oder wie so ein Stern oder wie so eine Koale? Das einmal durch und dann quasi so, halt wie man, wenn du jetzt ein Holz… Hast du die Rentenbilder dabei? Nein, wenn du so ein Holzast durchbrichst, dann bricht er ja nie so, wie du denkst, dass er bricht. Er bricht nicht in der Mitte durch, sondern du hast dann noch einen so einen spitzen, ne, so einen spitzen Rand. Und so ist es bei mir auch, du hast oben so einen spitzen Rand, so muss es zusammen geballert werden mit so einer Platte. Und gab es irgendwie Versuche, den Sturz zu rekonstruieren? Ja, von mir. Weil bei mir ging ja jetzt full blown Detective Mode an, weil ich dachte, was zum Teufel ist da passiert? Dann kam ich nach Hause und dann ist mir aufgefallen, ich bin ja mit Kopfhörern losgefahren und Musik. Wo sind meine Kopfhörer? Meine AirPods. Dann habe ich auf meinem Handy die Suchfunktion von meinen AirPods angemacht und sie lagen genau da, wo die erste ominöse Rollerfahrt geendet hat. Das ist Ende Folge zwei. Ja. Komm, lass uns noch eine Folge noch. Komm, ist jetzt egal. Und dann habe ich gesagt, habe ich vorne angerufen und gesagt, kannst du mich da hinbringen? Und sie hat gesagt, ja, komm, ich fahre dich da hin. Und dann sind wir hin zu der Unfallstelle und mir kam so zurück, was passiert ist, weil da ist nämlich genau, da ist ein Fahrradweg, selbstbewusster, ich kann die Langbrettern, Fahrradweg, und der hört auf und wird zu einer sehr viel gefahrenen Strasse. Und da habe ich wohl gesagt,
nö. Und da sieht es immer wieder aus wie ein Fahrradweg, aber es hat einen hohen Bordstein, also nicht so, aber uuuh. So hoher Bordstein. Und da bin ich wohl gegengefahren und dann umtippt, Kann ich mir vorstellen. Und dann lagen da zwei Kopfhörer. Komplett shredded, kaputt, 50.000 Einzelteile, platt gefahren, alles. Erst achtbar war meine Reaktion so, holy shit, was hatte ich denn für einen Unfall, bis mir auffiel, dass sie auf der Strasse lagen, wo ich einfach ein Auto drüber gefahren ist. Aber das Bild kann ich nicht mehr posten, das war einfach so über so einen Quadratmeter komplett verteilt, alle Einzelteile von so AirPods, sehr gruselig.
Und hast du dann noch da genau versucht zu rekonstruieren mit so einem Kreideumriss oder so, wie du da genau...
Ich war dann da mit meinen Wachsmalstiften und habe aufgemalt, was passiert ist.
Und ich glaube, genau, der Fahrradweg wird zur Strasse und da habe ich gesagt, umgedreht und da ist dann so, da ist dann einfach ein Bordstein hoher, da werde ich gegengefahren sein und dann umgekippt. Da waren auch richtig viele Splitter. Aber wo war der Roller? Hast du den da direkt beendet oder hast du den dann nochmal aufgenommen und bist weitergefahren? Ich schätze, ich bin aus dem Kopf gefallen, lag dann da vielleicht für eine Minute, bin dann aufgestanden, weitergegangen, Kopfhörer habe ich auch nicht mitgenommen, den Roller werde ich ja dann nicht auch noch mitgenommen haben, habe die Miete beendet. Ah, okay. Ich denke, das war mein Nummer eins Concern, dass ich nicht dafür noch zahle für diese Scheißdingen. Und dann bin ich dann wieder zu Sinnen gekommen. So gruselig. Wir müssen dahin. Wir müssen für die nächste Folge da hin und Fotos machen. Ich will das rekonstruieren. Ich will diesen weissen Stefan malen und dass wir wirklich das für immer da hin malen. Und jetzt, das Beste war dann, da war ich zu Hause und dachte mir, Moment, dann kann ich ja noch mehr rekonstruieren, wenn ich weiß, wo meine Kopfhörer rausgefallen sind. Weil, wenn man, kennt ihr vielleicht, wenn ihr diese Bluetooth-Kopfhörer habt, wenn man einen rausnimmt, dann hört die Musik auf. Also habe ich mein Handy aufgemacht und zum ersten Mal wieder auf Spotify bin ich gegangen und ich habe gesehen, bei welchem Song meine Nahtoderfahrung passiert ist. Und es war, und ich hoffe auch genau die Stelle, was? Danger Zone, fast. Ähnlicher Stil, ehrlich gesagt. Spielen wir ab. Saint Elmo's Fire. Und es ist so ein Song, ich verstehe schon, dass ich den besoffen gehört habe. Und ich habe dann dieses Spiel gemacht, das Spiel gemacht, ich bin noch nüchtern, alles gut, kein Problem.
Ja, stell dir vor, Stefan durch die Nacht auf dem Roller einfach, das Leben ist gut, die Jugend schmeckt süss im Fahrtwind der Nacht.
Und es war unironisch, zum ersten Refrain hat es aufgehört, wir hören kurz den Refrain und die Stelle, wo es aufgehört hat.
Weil es ist wirklich so ein, ich fahr durch Köln, die Nacht gehört mir, so Wind in meinen Haaren.
Und es ist literally, eine Lyric ist, the Eagles flying higher and higher. Und genau dazu, und es ist kein Scheiss, war es vorbei.
Wir hören in den Refrain rein, catchy Song. Geht sehr lang bis zum ersten Mal.
Einmal die Schlüsselbeine kreisen lassen, Freunde.
Yes! Es war eine lange Nacht. Was habe ich noch gehört?
Ich bin grinsend durch Köln gefahren und jetzt ist der abrupt gehört, weil die dann rausgefallen sind zu St. Elmo's Fucking Fire. Wow, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Das ist ein Song, zu dem man sterben kann. Uncool. Wahnsinn. Denn stell dir vor, das wäre der Song, zu dem ich gestorben wäre. Ja. Weil es war ja unironisch, einfach eine richtig doofe Situation, wo nicht viel passieren kann. Wir müssen das nachdrehen, wie du in Zeitlupe fliegst, der Kopfhörer fliegt aus deinem Ohr an der Kamera vorbei. Und jetzt ist meine Frage, und ich glaube, ich weiss ungefähr, welche Stelle du meinst, und wenn du es nicht machst, mache ich es. Ich werde da hingehen und ich schaue mich mal um, ob es da Kameras gibt. Ja. Weil, das würde mich schon interessieren, weil der Media-Park, dieser Platz, das ist alles gut beleuchtet, da sind Laternen und so. Da nicht mehr, da nicht mehr. Also da, das würde ich auch zustimmen, aber da, wo der Unfall passiert ist. Ich werde für euch da rausgehen und dieses Video suchen und ich werde es posten, wenn ich stimme. Also wir müssen das da rausnehmen. Und mit dieser Musik unterlegen. Zip! Also wirklich so uncool. Jetzt muss es zusammengedrückt werden, aber sonst ist alles gut. Aber ey, don't, why, macht's nicht, nehmt euch ein Taxi, geht zu Fuss. Ja, aber wir haben jetzt eigentlich gelernt, Helme sind überflüssig, oder? Ich weiß, mir ist mir auf den Kopf gefallen, da ist nichts passiert. Du ziehst immer die falsche Schlussfolgerung. Ja, also ichuche, also ich meine nur, du bist das beste Beispiel, du machst jetzt eine Antikampagne einfach so. Was war die Lehre, die du aus... Ohne Held geht es auch gut. Ja, aber ich habe jetzt echt überlegt, also ich werde so ein bisschen, weißt du, so Sinn suchen gerade schon. Wirklich, also du hast ein Nahtoderlebnis gehabt, an das ich mich erinnern kann. Okay, du hast zu einem Gott gesprochen, ich kann mich nur nicht erinnern, welcher verdammt nochmal. Ich hätte es wissen können, wer der echte Gott ist, aber nein, ich habe es vergessen. Ich bin jetzt nicht getreten. Ich weiß, welche Religion Recht hat. Ja, habe es aber vergessen. Fuck, ey. Aber dein Leben hat sich jetzt verändert, war er. Ich habe überlegt,, also ich habe mir echt überlegt, ob ich mir so einen, diesen Airbag-Helm kaufen soll, der so aussieht, als würde man einen Schal tragen und dann, wenn man einen Unfall hat, dann bildet sich ein großer Ballon um deinen Kopf. Den möchte ich gerne haben, einfach weil ich gehört habe, dass die auch Fehlzündungen haben. Ja, die haben vor allem Fehlzündungen, wenn man richtig wütend ist. Vor allem, ich dachte mir, nein! Es tut mir leid, Herr Tietze, die Eismaschine ist kaputt. Nein! Aber das Ding ist, vor allem wenn sie eine Fehlzündung haben und du fährst Fahrrad, hast du ja deswegen einen Unfall. Ja genau, du musst dann nicht auch stürzen lassen. Die sind doch nicht durchsichtig.
Da kannst du dann durchgucken und bist halt so Ballon.
Ja, stimmt.
Sperren die dir die Sicht?
Ja, die sperren dir die Sicht.
Dann hast du einen Unfall, weil dein Helm die jetzt zu sich rutscht.
Das ist schwierig.
Ich will das komplett, ich mach da ein True-Crime-Ding draus, ich will das komplett recherchieren,
ich werde zurückgehen.
Ich werde zurückgehen, ich werde alles konstruieren, wirklich alles bezeichnen.
Ich glaube, ich würde, habe ich mir letztens überlegt, weil ich schaue gerade die Serie von Jeffrey Dahmer, wie würde ich jemanden umbringen. Das überlege ich auch die ganze Zeit, weil ich gucke nämlich die ganze Zeit so Confession-Sachen, weil im Internet gibt es so mega, also bei YouTube sind so viele Verhöre und so, einfach komplett in vorderlänge drin. Man kann nicht mehr schlafen, danach ist ein großes Problem. Und vor allem, was ich machen würde, ich würde jemanden umbringen und dann liegt die Leiche halt irgendwo und dann... Wie würdest du den denn umbringen schon mal, also fangen wir schon mal an. Klassisch gefrorenes Hut, ich bin immer noch dabei, sorry, ich weiß, es gibt Kritiker, aber... Gefrorener Fasan. Gefrorener Fasan, erschlagen, dann heiß machen und essen, FBI ist so verwirrt wegen Fasan-DNA, so what? Und wegen des guten Geruchs in der Wohnung. Detective, ich glaube, wir müssen das Fasan einstellen. Hier ist ein Mensch tot, okay? Okay, kein Humor, okay, sorry. Und was ich dann machen würde, dann ist er tot und dann liegt er da und dann würde ich, wenn er schon da liegt, würde ich diesen weissen Umriss schon um ihn machen, sodass die Polizei kommt und sagt, okay, erst mal einen weissen Umriss. Moment mal, das ist der kleinste Mensch der Welt, weil du willst die Massstäbe verkacken. Ja, genau wie so die Hand.. Einfach so, das ist doch kein Moment. Heißt es, hier waren schon Detektives, die das gemacht haben und es dann vergessen haben? Aber das stimmt, du darfst nicht, du hast recht. Also angenommen, jemand würde so am Boden liegen mit der flachen Hand, du dürftest nicht jeden Finger, würde man dann jeden Finger nachmachen? Nein, ich glaube nicht, du machst das ganz grob. Aber du willst wahrscheinlich nicht so grob machen. Wenn man es zum ersten Mal macht, macht man es mir falsch. Und wenn da eine Blutlache ist, sprüht man dann da drüber oder muss man dann … Wie kommt man drunter? Weil ich würde deine Frisur ja auch malen. Ja. Ich würde ja nicht … Du hättest ja keinen runden Kopf bei mir, sondern du hättest so einen lockigen Kopf. Ja. Einfach so der Kunststudent, der das alles zu ernst nimmt. Ja. Ich kann so nicht arbeiten. Hier ist überall Blut, wie soll ich da rumgehen, das ist kein Titanium White, was soll ich damit machen, nee, tut mir leid, so kann ich nicht arbeiten. So Jackson Pollock-mäßig. Mit roter Farbe überall. Nicht das Blut nehmen, nicht das Blut nehmen. Ich glaube, du könntest so wirklich Leute verwirren einfach, weil ich glaube, das ist der coolste Teil am Mord, dann diesen Umriss zu machen. Was passiert, machen die da noch einen? Also würden die sagen, sorry, steht im Protokoll, oder würden die sagen, ne, passt? Was ist die Policy, wenn zwei Menschen übereinander sterben? Ja, gute Frage. Dafür haben wir die Sekundärfarbe Ocker. Die haben wir im Auto, die ist älter, die ist ein bisschen hart. Was passiert ist es passiert, wenn zwei Menschen übereinander sterben auf einem ockerfarbigen Grund?
Ne, weil würde man dann, malt man dann mit sich überkreuzenden Strichen oder malt man eine grosse? Das ist ein gutes Problem, ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Weiss jemand die Antwort? Ich glaube, man würde erst die Körperteile, die überlappen, des Oberen machen, dann den Oberen abnehmen, hinschreiben vielleicht, dann den unteren, ja genau, den Nahen, Harald, und dann den unterliegenden umkreisen, und dann den Bereich, der überlappt, so schraffieren, glaube ich. So würde ich es machen. Ich muss nichts wir müssen improvisieren. Aber es ist gute Frage. Bob Ross soll mir erklären, wie man das macht. Das ist eine wirklich verdammt gute Frage, ja. Ich weiß nicht die Antwort, niemand kennt die Antwort. Wir sind bei Fragen angekommen, wo niemand mehr die Antwort hat. Haben wir Kommissare im Raum, die einfach 19 Jahre für ihre Ausbildung brauchen, weil sie in der ersten Stunde zu viele Fragen gestellt haben.
Entschuldigung, was passiert, wenn drei Leichen übereinander sind und einer Ocker... Sie müssen erst das Gebäude verlassen.
Okay, alles klar. Entschuldigung. Sie stehen im Unterricht. Sie stehen im Polizeiunterricht.
Gut, dann komme ich morgen wieder, aber ich habe meinen Platz markiert.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie... Da saß ich, da saß ich!
Zurück zum Unterricht. eins, eins, null. Sagen diese Ziffern irgendwem irgendwas? Eins, ach es ist eins, eins, null? Oh, ich dachte mir, es ist eins, eins, null. Schon was gelernt hat sich das sehr gelohnt. Eins, eins, null. Du bist der einzige Mensch der Eins eins, schnell rufen Sie eins, eins, null an.
Was, was?
Und jeder Ersthelfer ist so verwirrt.
Entschuldigung, sagen Sie es noch mal.
Währenddessen Schwerverletzter, dass mir da niemand geholfen hat, übrigens, übrigens.
Oh ja, so jetzt wird's, jetzt, gut, gut, gut, weiter, weiter, Zivil ist sie tot? Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie stehe ich dann vor Publikum? Ich stehe, ich habe ein Mikrofon in der Hand. Du kannst doch mal einen Schritt nach vorne gehen, trau dich mal. Hi, ich bin Stefan, ich bin jetzt 28 geworden und komme aus Köln und ich will willkommen zu meinem Vortrag Ist Zivilcourage tot? Eine Studie in Scharlach-Roth. Sehr gut, Stefan. Toll. super, Stefan, super, super.
Danke.
Aber? Danke, Sir. Handtuch-Idee. Toter Fasan. Gut, auch gut, merkst du, macht dir einen Haken. Notiere ich mir. Ein Handtuch, also jetzt so ein Strandhandtuch, wir reden über ein Strandhandtuch. Und es ist wie so ein Asphaltboden, so denkt an New Yorker Boden, irgendwie Asphalt, Glassplitter. Und dann so die weißen Umrisse von den Menschen und man liegt da drauf am Strand. Das ist doch super lustig. Habe ich schon mal bei Instagram gesehen, Instagram-Werbung. Verdammt! Scheiße, ne? Scheiße. Wer klaut mir hier die ganzen Ideen? Aber kann man das custom machen? Kann man das dann selber ein Foto von sich einschicken und dann machen die das genauso, die Umrisse, das ist ein geiles Geschenk. Aber dann kannst du dich nicht, dann kannst du dich leider nicht umdrehen, am Strand zumindest nicht. Du kannst nicht mit einem coolen Trick und machen uns das vor, so begeisterst du die Leute am Strand, aber wenn du das nicht machen kannst, dann liegst du die ganze Zeit halt genau wie die Umrisse da, muss immer so liegen. Es gibt so viele True Crime Fans. Ich glaube, das ist ein geiles Geschenk. So speziell angefertigt. Oder so diese Zettel, die man so um den Zeh hängt bei Leichen im Totenhaus, Paläontololium oder so. Das ist auch geil. So als Schmuck. Fussschmuck ist eh, finde ich, eine Baustelle, Freunde. Da haben wir, finde ich, als Zivilisation auch echt noch irgendwie noch was blinkend offen, so To-Do-List. Fingerschmuck, Halsschmuck, super. Surfer haben doch immer am Fuss, und wenn die ihre Flip-Flops anhaben, haben die doch so kleine feine Bändchen da, wie so Freundschaftsbändchen. Ja, vom Knöchelbändchen. Um die Fesseln, um die Fesseln, um die Fesseln, um die Fesseln, um die Fesseln, niemand nickt, um die Fesseln, um die Fesseln. Wie lange muss ich das machen, bis Leute gehen, bis Leute endlich deine Gummifessel kaufen. Ich glaube, da ist noch, also ich habe noch nie Fußschmuck gesehen, wo ich dachte, das ist dein. Sorry an alle, die jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wer mit beschmückten Füssen hier erschienen ist heute.
Aber hast du generell mal irgendwo gesagt, das ist ein geiler Schmuck für mich?
Ich bin neidisch auf, ich finde Ringe richtig cool.
Du findest Ringe richtig cool?
Ich bin leider nicht so ein Schmucktyp, das nervt die ganze Zeit und ich würde ihn verlieren auch sofort
und ich wäre zu vorsichtig und so, aber so coole Ringe, das ist schon immer ganz geil. Weil du gerade jetzt Hände Ringe guckst oder was? The Rings of Power. Auch. Ich hätte gerne Ring of Power. Ja, aber auch da gibt es coole Ringe. Du willst immer das aus der letzten Serie, was du gerade guckst. Ja, stimmt. Erst war da ein bisschen mit Breaking Bad durch. Erst wollte ich morden, jetzt will ich Ringe. So eine Scheisszeit. Aber jetzt guckst du Jeffrey Dahmer. Ja. Allerdings, die ganze Staffel. Ich habe jetzt aber auch wirklich dann so angefangen, so Confessions zu gucken. Der hat ja Sachen gegessen auch, ne? Der hat seine Opfer gegessen? Der hat seine Sachen gegessen, aber es hieß in der Doku auch, es ist nicht so, dass der alle seine Opfer gegessen hat, sondern der hat es mal probiert. Also es war mal so eine Idee und dann hat er es anscheinend auch angebraten. Und ich frage mich wirklich, also hat man dann auch, macht man dann Ketchup drauf oder was ist dann? Es hat ihm ja anscheinend nicht gut genug geschmeckt. Hat er das dann einfach so in Müll oder hat er gesagt, komm jetzt mit Ketchup oder wie macht er das? Hat mal jemand aus Spaß bei Chefkoch.de Mensch angegeben. Ja, ach komm, ich glaube der Gag ist doch überholt, Mensch. Der Gag ist doch so eine flambierte Hand oder sowas. Halloween steht um die Decke, bald. Halloween steht vor der Tür, ich wollte keine Angst machen, niemand steht vor der Tür. Und deswegen glaube ich, das ist doch ein netter Halloween-Prank. Mein Gott, schnell fahren, macht einen schönen flambierenden Knöchel auf chefkoch.de. Ich finde das süss. Weißt du, ob der Kannibale von Rotenburg, der ist auch angebraten, scharf angebraten? Ich weiss es nicht, er weiss noch, ob der ein Rezept ist. Der ist nicht scharf angebraten, glaube ich. Ich weiss nur, dass er es in Gefriertruhe gemacht hat, damit es halt ein bisschen länger haltbar ist. Das fand ich auch clever. Wen fragt man dann da? Wie lange hält Menschenfleisch? Also du bist ja dann auch super auf dich selber angewiesen, deine Kochkünste. Ja, ja, total. Du gehst dann so zum Arzt und sagst so, ja, nee, nee.
Eine Frage noch.
Welches Körperteil, würden Sie sagen, hat am wenigsten Fett?
Weil, also nicht im Sinne von, also wo, also was ist so mager oder was ist so?
Ich denke, Nase.
Nase?
Fett, ja.
Aha.
Ja, so Ohren haben auch wenig Fett.
Und was würden Sie also sagen?
Finger, würde ich sagen.
Vier, fünf Minuten oder also...
Wie meinen Sie?
Also, nee, nee, jetzt im, nee, okay, gut, dann alles klar.
Nee, nee, was war Ihre Frage?
Ja, also wie lange, also ist es eher dicke Fleisch oder dünnes Fleisch oder eher...
Sie kennen doch Ohren.
Nicht so gut, ehrlich gesagt, Sie haben Ohren studiert. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was genau Ohren sind. Hat jemand Ohren studiert? Nein, nein. Sind Sie ein Arzt oder nicht? Sie kennen doch mit Ohren aus. Ich bin Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Arzt. Und bei dem ganzen Ohren-Blog habe ich gefehlt. Schlüsselbeinbruch. Ich glaube, Ohren nehmen viel Soße auf. Ich glaube, die sind gut. Wieso Gnocchi? Ja, das sagt man ja auch über Pastasorten. Und das ist so das einzige Argument für Pastasorten. Ich mag ja Penner am liebsten, die nehmen am meisten Soße auf. Ich mag ja Verfalle am liebsten, weil die nehmen am meisten Soße auf. Aber bei Spaghetti kann man mir das nicht erzählen. Dieser Pasta-Diskurs dreht sich nur um einen, weil ich denke mir, Freunde, wie wärst du mit einem Löffel? Wenn ihr Bock auf Soße habt, dann esst fucking Soße. Ihr könnt aus dem Kochtopf. Ihr wisst schon, dass Nudeln nicht das beste Werkzeug sind, um Soße zu transportieren. Nehmt eine Dose. Für eine komische Zeit in der Belebung, wenn es nur um die Oberflächenbeschaffenheit und Oberflächendichte von Pastasorten geht. Aber Spaghetti ist doch am schlechtesten man dafür geeignet, um Soße aufzunehmen, oder? Es gibt Leute, die das so sagen oder so. Für mich, also ich mag kein heisses Essen, ich bin wirklich der festen Überzeugung, dass kaltes Essen besser schmeckt als warmes Essen. Moment. Ja, ich weiß, es kommt dazu hin, dazu hin, setzt sich hin. Aber warm hast du jetzt ignoriert. Du hast die vielen Stufen zwischen heiß und kalt ignoriert. Red weiter. Was ist mit Lauwa? Was ist mit Lau-kalt?fekt-Warm? Du hast meine Aufmerksamkeit? Sieht nicht so aus. Es sieht aus, als ob es gleich auf dein Schlüsselbein fällt. Und ich würde dich dafür abraten. Weil es sieht echt aus wie gute Sportübungen, ehrlich gesagt. Nee, komm, ist auch Quatsch jetzt. Und deswegen wollte ich nur sagen, meine beste Pastasorte sind Penne, weil bei Penne kann man durchpusten. Meine beste Pastasorte Penne. Meine beste Pastasorte Penne, weil da kann man durchpusten. Man kann direkt durchpusten, und das ist wie so ein Windkanal. Man kann nicht die Penne durchpusten, denn ich denke, dass ich eine Lieblingspastasorte Penne durchpusten. Ich liebe Penne-Pusten, das ist einfach mein größtes Wort Paul, du kannst doch schon eine Penne durchpusten. Es ist ein päpstlich prächtiges Penne-Pusten, wenn ich mal koche.
Es ist aber nicht päpstlich, als ein Papst, um eine Penne durchzupusten.
Kann man aber, glaube ich, auch nicht cool essen, glaube ich.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das dann so, okay, und was machst du so beruflich? Ich übe schon fürs Stäbchen, wenn ich betrunken angehalten werde. Sie können mal gucken, wie lange ich pusten kann und dann der Polizist so, ah, Penneliebhaber? Aber die haben mir wirklich danach das Röhrchen geschenkt, das heisst, du kannst auch dein Röhrchen selber mitbringen.
Das heisst, du kannst einfach so eine Penne rausholen.
Das ist ein geiler Move, wenn die dich anhalten, wenn du hast.
Und dann sagt er so, ja okay, sie sind zu 100% Penne.
Ja, allerdings ist es illegal.
Sie sind verhaftet.
Penne sind in sehr vielen Staaten gesucht.
Wo würden Sie mir die Handschellen anlegen?
Wo würden Sie da Penne eine Handschellen anlegen?
Haben Sie das in Ihrer Kommissarsausbildung gelernt?
Scheiße.
Oder haben Sie da geschlafen?
Einmal oben und einmal unten.
Und dann geht es zu...
Rabioli.
Nee. Was ist Penne genau? So, jetzt stellen wir die Fragen. Niemand weiss, was ein Schlüsselbein ist, niemand weiss, was Penne sind. Nee, Penne sind rund und durchpustbar, richtig? Der Pust, eher reichend. Durchpustbare Penne und leicht geriffelt. Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, man kann, also wenn du angehalten wirst von der Polizei und die sagst, blasen sie bitte ins... Ich glaube, man kann auch Nein sagen, ehrlich gesagt. Oder du kannst sagen, ich habe mal Aufsatz am Schlüsselbund. Du hast deinen eigenen Pusteraufsatz dabei. Das ist doch mal eine Ansage, oder? Wie so ein Chip für den Wagen. Ich wäre direkt suspicious. Ich würde denken, warum wird er so oft angehalten, dass er inzwischen aus Praktizitätsgründen, er hat nicht mal eine Jacke an. Und er flutet am Kopf. Augenscheinlich. Warum hat er das, um sein Leben zu vereinfachen? Ich glaube, ich könnte überdurchschnittlich gut pusten, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich mag auch Kohlensäure nicht so gern, weswegen ich Kohlensäure immer so zu 60% ausschüttel aus Getränken oder halt früher, als man Strohallen benutzt hat, habe ich das halt schön weggeblubbert.
Und da habe ich, glaube ich, wirklich stundenlang, weil ich finde, ich mag Kohlensäure, aber ich mag es nur so ein bisschen, nur so ein bisschen, nicht so viel, sonst tun meine Zähne weh.
Also, beim Essen liebst du kalt. Ja, Essen kalt. Ja. Gibt es nur 0 oder 1 für dich. Ja. Bei der Beschaffenheit des Kohlensäureanteils hast du sehr viele Stufen. Ja. Und wenn ich kein Stroharm habe... Und dann teilst du dich für sehr wenig Kohlensäure. Wenn ich kein Stroharm habe, dann nehme ich eine Penne und blase damit in mein Getränk, so lange bis der Kohlensäure gehalten ist. Fussisch. Ich mag das, wenn man so richtig viel trinkt, so richtig ganz, und Kohlensäure steht ihm im Weg, Kohlensäure ist wie so ein Stopp, wie so, hey, pass auf, das ist zu viel. Aber bist du auch deswegen Reis und Brokkoli Fan? Ja, ich mag grosse Mengen, ich mag, ich wüsste gar, was ich esse. Ey, wenn man Sand essen könnte, boah,, boah, setzt mich in der Wüste aus, Freunde, boah, wie so ein Skorpion, der sich so in den Sand eingräbt. Schatz, der Mann, der auf seiner eigenen Silhouette liegt, isst jetzt Sand. Oh, am Strat der sehr traurig. Schatz, guck nicht hin. Er saugt durch eine Penne den ganzen Sand aus. Gibt es irgendein Essen, das wie Sand ist?
Reis kommt dem schon ein bisschen nach. Oh, Couscous.
Na, das ist mir auch noch zu... Ich will wirklich so pulverig, so wie Kakaopulver, aber halt essbar.
So ein Löffel Zimt.
Ja, aber so...
Zimt, das Sand der Küche.
Ich glaube, ich bin wirklich einfach einer der bemitleidendsten, wertesten Menschen der Welt.
Ja, sehe ich auch so, völlig richtig.
Das war die, das Podcast auf Kultur.
Weil mein Lieblingsessen gibt es nicht.
Hey, mein Lieb... Nein!
Ich würde dich ja umarmen, aber ich habe nur eine Handfeuille.
Nein!
Hey, es sieht immer kumpelig aus, wenn ich dich jetzt umarme, ist es nur... Es ist so, als ob du dich nicht ganz trauen würdest. Weißt du, jeder Mensch hat ein Lieblingsessen. Ja. Und wenn ich immer gefragt werde, was mein Lieblingsessen ist, dann sage ich immer Sand oder Blumenerde. Und dann sagen die anderen immer, aber das kann man nicht essen. Und dann sage ich, ja, ich weiß. Können Sie das auch einen Moment in Ihrer Kindheit zurückführen? Hat Sand im Leben Ihrer Mutter eine große Rolle gespielt oder so? Sorry, Entschuldigung, ich habe parallel an eine Folge Steinfeld gedacht, deswegen muss ich lachen. Ich lache nicht über Ihre Vergangenheit. Meine Mutter hatte eine grosse Sanduhr. Und immer wenn ich was falsch gemacht habe, dann hat sie die Sanduhr umgedreht und hat mich aus dem Raum geschickt für die Dauer, die die Sanduhr abgelaufen ist. Nein, das war auch Ihre, das war ich, das bin ich Therapeut. Ach so, ich verwechsel das. Vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum ich Sand aufessen will, um diese Schuld aufzuessen und weil es köstlich ist. Eines Tages, ihr werdet sehen, da werde ich Sand braten und zubereiten und es wird die größte Delikatesse der Welt und ich werde sie mich rein essen und die ganze Wüste wird aufgegessen von mir. Das war unsere Show. Das war's, danke München!
Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Unklo.
Das war unsere letzte Show, die letzte Show der Tour.
Und sie war natürlich mit Stefan Tietze.
Und Florian Will, vielen, vielen Dank!
Das war München. und wir heben ab!